so yeah it's just interesting what's
going on with the high school because i
listen maybe this shows how like old i
am i just can't fathom there's like a
whole high school that's that's watching
the special going this was so incredibly
offensive to this one community
that we can't even have him speaking
this is a performing arts high school so
it's probably a lot of lgbt so there's a
bunch of kids
that were wanting to walk out oh they're
like you think japan went to a black
high school oh yeah my bad that's great
that's right that's what are we talking
about that's nuts this guy's from silver
spring maryland
him and blower neighbors get out of here
right yeah hey well you're welcome
chappelle white people
i made nice performing arts high schools
well apparently not that nice because he
had to like go and donate a bunch of
money to it and they were supposed to
change the name of the theater to make
it dave chappelle dave chappelle theater
yeah oh and they and they didn't
actually cancel it they just post
postponed it
they need that check bruh they literally
said they were postponing to april yeah
they wanted to be closer to pride month
let's do it at a time where this way
when they walk out they might be going
to the parade exactly yeah yeah they're
like yeah they'll be out of school
anyway yeah it's a holiday for them damn
man
whatever let the kids do it i don't know
[Laughter]
wait what [ __ ] i'm like so like
exhausted by the discussion it's crazy
how that's what i'm saying
if trump was in office this [ __ ] would
have gone away in two weeks
there would have been some other
controversy trump would have said
something and then people would have
pushed a pell to the side uh
i'd been napping this whole [ __ ] time
i would have covered this up a lot
hundred percent yeah yeah yeah now that
is true things moved quicker we got over
things faster yeah definitely in the
trump era he just gave us much more to
sink our teeth into he gave us fodder
man just move on let's go what's the
next thing
but yeah yeah it's tricky man i don't
know i don't know how long this is going
to last
i guess it will last as long as people
uh have the ability to virtue signal
and i'd be okay
to be honest like
i'm okay if people push back like you
have the freedom to do that do whatever
the [ __ ] you want
i i just don't like this idea that
the jokes kill trans people
um yeah it's a little extreme the jokes
are literally violence yeah yeah
this is literal violence and this is how
trans people get killed and it's like
someone who's ready to kill a trans
people person like they didn't need to
see the special yeah you know what i
mean like there's not first of all i
don't even know if there's people on the
fence with murdering trans people i
think you're very clearly on one side of
that on the other side
and um and then those who do it are just
going to do it but like the special is
not helping you they're not making it
that time into the special anyways 40
minutes in you think they're watching
the whole [ __ ] thing yeah for the
trans hate they're not smart enough to
have that attention span yeah nah bruh
they feel how they feel my jokes do not
incite hate they do not yeah they are
jokes judge me about my intentions yes
the intention is to make you laugh and
you know maybe a little crazy yeah
that's it that's a dope form of comedy
though like hate inciting comedy
you gotta be nice with your [ __ ] sick
unless the audience is moshing like i
don't think the the jokes are inciting
violence yeah
if they're moshing at the show then i'm
like i can see it like there's a vibe
happening i mean yeah i just don't
understand how someone could go to a
comedy show and then after their want to
like murder trans people and that's what
they're saying
i mean that's what some people are
saying like that's the literally
violence i see that tweet a lot i think
most people are saying it's like
normalizing an attitude against trans
people yeah i could see that yeah and
that be and i could see you being
frustrated by that frustrator
and you're out here like yo i'm not
[ __ ] lying about this [ __ ] yeah i'm a
girl yeah right
which to someone who's not trans is a
wild statement yeah right like you see a
person that looks like a dude go i'm a
girl yeah you're like okay
but deep down you're like no
but you can't say that because then
that's they look at you like you ever
seen a cat that acts like a dog that's
how they look at you i've never seen
that oh sound there's never seen a cat
that plays fetch
no really
no oh no they got it is that what you
meant by a cat that acts like a dog yeah
yeah they got casted legit they'll play
fetch they'll do all this dog ass
behavior yeah i mean that's what
that's the best pet ever yeah that's
awesome it's 100 percent a dog with
personal responsibility yeah yeah yeah
it's just uh yeah it's an autonomous dog
but you you you gotta luck out and get
one otherwise you get a cat cat and
that's something you can't train it to
be there no it's not [ __ ] you're just
born that way pure luck you're just born
that way yeah yeah yeah i made you that
way
yeah yeah you were a signed dog at birth
but you're actually a transgender yeah
yeah and that should be proof if nothing
else that trans is real yeah
i mean we're still talking about it
right now what if we just do like
remember like a day without a mexican
remember that thing yeah
wait what you don't remember that guys
no it was like it was a holiday every
year they would do like a day without a
mexican i think like what happens like
mexicans don't work that day holiday
every
holiday
there was a day without a mexican wasn't
it yeah but it was a movie oh it was a
movie what are you talking about
holiday what is the date without a
mexican yeah mexicans don't have to be
mexican that day what do they dress up
idea that they're that they're integral
in all parts of our daily life but then
under appreciated blah blah blah and
let's see what happens when you're not
mexican
falls apart didn't they didn't they do
like a bunch of white people just
getting jobs they hate yeah [ __ ]
miserable
pretty rough dude there's a but no
didn't they do something like last year
where they're like uh like for like a
week or for a day it was like only spend
money on black businesses black people
did this yeah i remember that right and
it was like a way of putting like
economic sanctions on everybody that's
not black right right right i think that
basically the day without a mexican i
think it was like if you're a mexican
like just stay home don't work that day
so everybody can feel how integral you
are to the u.s economy
right
and um we know
i don't think there's anybody who's like
we couldn't do this or we could do this
without mexicans yeah i think we all
know how valuable and important mexicans
are right we're not gonna pay them
anymore because they're mexicans yeah
yeah but that's why you're so integral
yes it's because you do it all but we
don't really pay you yeah that's why we
need you yes come on yes and now's the
time i mean like you know what's so
funny like we're trying to like stop
these like caravans from coming into the
united states of america and then in the
same breath we're like we need more
employees it's time to hire anybody we
can't get anybody to come work
we can't get anybody to work at
restaurants we can't get anybody to do
anything and we literally have all these
people knocking on the door like we work
at garages we work at restaurants we do
all the jobs that you need to hire
people for and you refuse to do because
you were given 1300 twice yeah the wall
is causing a labor shortage there it is
right there you don't even have the wall
but like we clearly have an issue right
like on the same news broadcast
people
need to be hired for these jobs we have
supply shortages because there's labor
labor shortages nobody's going to go do
the job we can't deliver after 12. every
[ __ ] hotel so i'm sorry we can't
clean unless you ask us to clean because
there's nobody to do it every restaurant
in room dining and every [ __ ] thing
oh we don't do that anymore because we
can't hire anybody there are people
the same people you hire ready to go
am i making a bad argument here no
that's a great point let the caravans in
who's not working
but you got to disperse them though you
got to have some type of bus system to
get them uh around the country that's
the caravan dog they'll
yes we were just in chicago tons of
mexicans yeah they'll find a way dude
they will i'm not worried about that i'm
just saying like that should be the
ultimatum that's what i would do to
americans you better start working are
we letting these [ __ ] in yo get
to work yeah you know what i mean no
more of these unemployment [ __ ] we like
cause once they're in there's no chance
for you yeah the only reason if you're
white and you're like a dishwasher or
some [ __ ] like that the only reason you
have a job is because that restaurant
has never had a mexican do the job yeah
once they hire a mexican it's over
you're never working again yeah you have
one shot yeah you have one shot get your
[ __ ] ass back to work or go to school
yeah do something but once they hire the
mexicans it's over bro yeah have you
ever seen a business have a mexican
workforce and then all of a sudden not
have a mexican workforce no yeah ins
comes through that's the way they get
more mexicans
you don't once you go mexican you don't
go anywhere else i'm being serious name
one business
you can't name one chinese people hire
mexicans
even other minorities who come here to
bust their ass look at their own people
and there's enough [ __ ] chinese
people trust me yeah they look at their
own people and they're like you can't do
this yeah you can't
do chinese [ __ ]
[Laughter]
mexicans are better at doing chinese
[ __ ]
than chinese people unbelievable
that's a good what do you mean what
what's confusing about this son you go
into a you go into a chinese restaurant
they got mexican dudes making chinese
[ __ ]
yeah
okay well we have to have a mexican face
up front and then everybody else in the
back is mexican
chinese [ __ ] though say what else is
like chinese [ __ ] food food dogs
well most things are probably chinese
[ __ ] everything that we're wearing or
sitting on is probably made in china
right now yeah and if they had mexicans
out there they'd [ __ ] use them i
guarantee you yeah i guarantee you i'm
being serious
this is we need to play hardball with
americans yeah this is your last chance
to work forever